envoys from the economic community of
West African states are expected to
arrive in Burkina Faso on Tuesday
following the country's second military
coup in less than nine months the new
leader Ibrahim troar has accepted the
resignation of the country's now
ex-president Paul Andrei San Diego dam
was toppled by Junior army army officers
on Friday and he's now fled to
neighboring Togo the coup has sparked
concern among world powers as the region
battles a growing islamist Insurgency
new self-declared leader he has promised
to tackle insecurity and appeal for
Unity to fix the country's problems
we need to speed things up the entire
country faces an emergency so each one
at their own level must go faster and
Abandon All cumbersome under necessary
red tape
hundreds of people have marched through
the streets of the capital to celebrate
the goal
no one will threaten the existence of
this country we have to fight for our
country fight Army we support you
we came out to support Captain trauray
for Real Change we are out to show our
support so he can Implement what he said
in his statement
the military has been fighting a violent
jihadist Insurgency for the last seven
years the state has lost control of more
than a third of the country thousands
have been killed and nearly 2 million
people have been displaced due to the
conflict
many are suffering from severe food
insecurity
Burkina faso's new leader faces a series
of extremely tough challenges to tackle
the humanitarian crisis and quell the
islamist Insurgency
Henry Wilkins is a journalist in
wilgudugu he told us about the
atmosphere in the capital and how it's
changed since the coup
yes so the the scenes on the streets
here today have been a lot calmer than
they were over the over the weekend
um you know over the weekend there were
there were soldiers on the street there
were protesters on the street although
there have been sporadic protests today
and celebrations for the uh for the new
Junta it's relatively small numbers of
people that have that have come out onto
the streets but certainly things are a
lot calmer than they were over the
weekend
now we have seen as we saw in that
report there does appear to be support
for the new leader what explains that
well I think the the insecurity is
really what explains that I mean I've
spoken to probably 10 12 book and Arby's
today
um who just all of them are in support
of the of the new Junta I think there's
kind of a sense of desperation here
um you know they had the democratic
government for around five years they
have the last military agenda for only
eight months but neither of those
governments have proved to be effective
in uh sorting out the security problems
that the the country is facing because
of it it's it's the seven year conflict
with militants linked to Islamic States
and Al-Qaeda I think you know there's a
sense of well where do we turn now and
now stepping into this chaotic scene our
envoys from the West African block
ecowas they say they're going to be
going to Burkina Faso what is their
message going to be
yeah I mean with the with the previous
Junta they uh ecowas managed to get them
to commit to a two-year transition
period where in theory they would sort
out the security in that time and then
transition back to to a democratic uh
Society I dare say that that's probably
what they're going to try and do with
this Mugen tour as well
um whether they'll be successful is
another question uh this genter is I
think you said earlier has talked about
cutting the red tape and it seems like
they want some hard and fast Solutions
how much they're going to be willing to
listen to the regional community and The
Wider International Community is uh yet
to be seen Henry Wilkins the journalist
Aaron wilgudugu thanks very much for the
latest
see